stellt euch mal vor ihr ladet ein
youtube video hoch und es bekommt 0
aufrufe das wär schon ziemlich
beschissen die website youtube sucht
einem zufällig irgendein video auf
youtube rauslassen 0
aufrufe hat und da schauen wir uns jetzt
mal ein bisschen durch
[Musik]
ich habe auch acht kinder mit tempo
gleichzeitig schaffen jetzt
aktualisieren wird uns direkt ein
anderes video mit 0 aufrufen
angezeigt wird er mich erschießen wir
zusammen sie lassen sich genauso summe
allerdings direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten video mit nur aufrufen uns war
es das hier
ich tippe auf play der fährt mit einem
boot
ebenso lang aber er sieht wunderschön
aus bei dem mit tiefblaues wasser hier
ist ein riesiger strand hier sind
viele freunde
ja
auch danke für deinen herr beitragen
kein plan was ihr gerade abgeht ich bin
ein bisschen vor
bei mir kommt ihnen typ auf dem motorrad
her gefahren und das war's also auch
danke für dein video ich trage mich echt
warum sowas nun aufrufe h das jetzt das
nächste video emder chatten zwei leute
auf französisch glaube ich die julia
zusammen mit dem patrice sap wer sie und
die wie neue größe to supermessi ein
paar sekunden später sagte er es werde
werbung für messenger für sowas wie
whatsapp aber nächstes währung für eine
mülltonne die werbung nicht wir
eingegangen ist kommen allerdings direkt
zum nächsten video mit 0 aufruf uns was
ist das hier das läuft schon
es passiert nichts und das video ist
jetzt vorbei da wird mir das offene
training der nationalmannschaft
vorgeschlagen
auch das ganz klar behält die nummer
eins spielt darauf das tor was ja schön
wieder fußball spielen
cool das ist ein hammer vorne video
degas beim allerdings direkt beim gaming
und zwar ist das nächste video das hier
da spielt jemand far cry und er hängt
irgendwo fest er hüpft und kommt nicht
raus und das ist so zeigt das
langweiligste video das hier gesehen
habe aber ich möchte vielleicht ist das
nächste video mit nun aufrufe
interessanter uns was ist das hier ein
tick tock video ohne ton
was kann ich davon vielleicht und man in
slow motion sehen ja geil alter wahnsinn
geil würde ich direkt so auf tik tok
hochladen
ich dachte erst es verkackt die total
aber dass dies gut alltag sie brauchst
du das am kleinen stand hier damit sie
ihre füße da hinstellen kann mach weiter
so also da würde ich ja direkt
zuschlagen wollen bei sonne geilen karte
kommen allerdings direkt zum nächsten
zufällig ausgewählten youtube video das
sich noch niemand bisher angeschaut hat
tiere in japan jährige lernt
der gelernte wenn ich jetzt die
französische in dem video oder wasser
red shirt von und station in disentis
heißt es also wie man wörter auf
französisch ausspricht geil alter habe
ich mich schon immer gefragt aber gut
aber direkt weiter mit dem nächsten
video mit 0 aufrufen uns war es das hier
[Musik]
ich sehe das ganz genauso ganz genau so
wie du es an meiner einschätzung noch
eigentlich waren einst das video hier
sind ein paar frettchen sind das glaube
ich oder kanal und er doch ich glaube
dass ein frettchen in ihrem gehege was
einfach nur aus ziegelsteinen steht die
kraxeln auf jeden fall alle ein bisschen
rum haben da den spaß ihres lebens haben
auch noch ein bisschen was zu fressen
stehen also das ist tatsächlich das
erste mal ein video wo ich wirklich
sagen muss das war's jetzt auch schon
wieder
allerdings zum letzten video das wir uns
heute zufällig generiert auf dieser
webseite anschauen und zwar ist das hier
nicht das ist ein holzmodell das ist
beeindruckend allerdings interessiert
mich wirklich herzlich wenig anders
stellt das sollte ich mich das alles
auch beende meine lieben freunde wenn
euch meine reaktion auf die tube also
die webseite die einem zufälligerweise
irgendwelche youtube videos mit 0
aufrufen an zeit gefallen hat dann das
gerne einen daumen hoch unter diesem
video abonniert main kanal falls noch
keine luxus sein und dieses t shirt hier
ist vor einigen tagen in lucka -
shopping.de gelaunt ist das schiff die
fifties miley shirt und wenn ihr euch
das gefällt dann schaut gern beim nokia
kam
[Musik]